in a world that's changing so quickly
the biggest risk you can take is not
taking any risk you don't have all the
answers and that's okay and that you're
gonna figure it out along the way
and most people don't take enough risk
especially early in your career rise and
shine it's an espresso time good morning
belief nation it's Evan my one word is
believe and I believe in you I believe
you have an amazing gift inside you that
I want to see exploded onto the world so
let's start your day off right together
grab your coffee and sip on today's
message take risks over to you Mark
Zuckerberg in a world that's changing so
quickly the biggest risk you can take is
not taking any risk and I really think
that that's true right a lot of people I
think think that you know whenever it
comes to whatever you get yourself into
a position where you have to make some
some big shift and direction or do
something you know there are always
people are going to point to the
downside risks of that decision and
locally there may be right right I mean
if for any given decision that you're
gonna make there's upside and downside
but in aggregate if you are stagnant and
you don't make those changes then then I
think you're guaranteed to fail right
and not not catch up so to some degree I
think it's really right that over time
the biggest risk that you can take is to
not take any risks the biggest risk is
not taking a risk at all I love it so
many people are so afraid to follow
their dreams to have this big idea that
they have that they want to go off and
accomplish we have this big vision for
ourselves and we're so afraid of making
the wrong decision that we do nothing
that you see this big goal and you have
three four or five potential paths and
you have limited resources limited time
limited money limited abilities and you
want to say I need to make the perfect
decision because if I make the wrong one
it all falls apart
and as a result we get paralyzed by fear
and we do nothing and that's the biggest
risk of all that's when you see somebody
else making tons of money off your ideas
that's when you fast forward ten years
and you still haven't done anything
you're still in the exact same position
that you are now meanwhile lots of
people have taken that idea that you had
and are crushing it and so the way to
get over it is to recognize that as soon
as you get an idea you need to find some
small way to test it and that you don't
have all the answers and that's okay and
that you're gonna figure it out along
the way
don't be naive like I was to think that
you can create a business plan and it's
going to be the perfect business plan
you're gonna have all the answers
figured out and then you're just gonna
execute that business plan because as
soon as you finish writing your business
plan and you get out into the world and
you start testing your assumptions
you'll find out that you made a lot of
mistakes that a lot of what you thought
would happen didn't happen you couldn't
predict the future you couldn't predict
how customers would react you can't come
up with the perfect plan just sitting in
your apartment sitting on your couch
going to the library you have to
actually get out start talking to
customers test your assumptions that was
my biggest problem in my first business
I spent three months working on the
perfect business plan and then when I
got out to market I realized a lot of
what I thought was gonna happen a lot of
what I thought what the reactions would
be is now what actually happened and
that set me behind and so being attached
to that perfect idea understand that
that doesn't exist there is no perfect
plan there is no perfect idea as soon as
you get something in your head as soon
as you get an idea for something to do
then find some small way to get out and
start testing it find some small way to
get out and start seeing are you getting
yeses are you getting traction do you
even enjoy this a lot of times these big
goals that we have for ourselves when
you get into it you want to be a
youtuber great you start making videos
you're like yeah I don't really like
that go figure that out as soon as
possible people wait years before they
go and try their first attempt at it and
then you realize you know what that
wasn't for me and so I strongly
encourage you to one as soon as you get
an idea for something something you want
to test out something that you think
might work find some immediate way to
test it on a small scale don't take a
big risk don't go mortgage your house
don't go take out a giant loan I hate
spending money till I'm making money
fine
some small way to get started and then
to used a fear of regret use that idea
of that if I don't do anything that in
in 60 years you're gonna look back in
your life and say I really wish that I
took some action on it I'll give you a
concrete example of what I'm going
through right now with YouTube I feel
like this is my moment I feel like I
know what I'm doing I feel like I have
my window however long it's gonna last
it could be six months twelve months 24
months I gotta push as hard as I can I
feel like we're really hitting it I
think it's a great combination of
everything that I love doing my skill
sets my interest my passion right now to
provide value to myself and to you guys
and so it's why I'm pushing hard I'm
making three videos a day I go to my
website I had a shift where I said you
know what I want to solve the world's
biggest problem untapped human potential
what does that look like I don't know
when I first launched it I had no idea I
deleted my entire website through up one
picture and that was my home page if you
go right now you'll see it's still a
bunch of pictures I had a little bit
more meat to the bones but I still don't
know where it's going I don't have all
the answers around it I'm still trying
to figure it out but I figure it out by
doing by testing by having conversations
and so from an SEO perspective my
website sucks but I wasn't interested in
the direction I was going anymore
I switched and so I had to find a way to
get started and so I did it myself
my website has now what I call the
circle potential and all of those points
you can click on it and dive a little
bit deeper somebody made a comment when
he clicked on the first version of my
self-awareness button he said well it's
only promoting your stuff it should have
a wider range you're right I don't know
the answer yet I'm figuring it out and
so I don't let the fear of making
mistakes prevent me from doing anything
because if I waited until I had the
whole thing figured out what the perfect
website would look like I'd never launch
it and having a website that's not
complete and building some momentum with
it drives me to want to do more on it
drives me want to figure out more
details on it and so some pages are more
worked out than others but all of them
need a lot more work and it just came
from that initial ID
that initial thesis that as soon as you
have an idea for something you find
immediate ways to take action on it
because the momentum is so so so so so
so important the biggest risk of all is
not taking any risk at all now I have a
special bonus clip for you but before
getting to that my question of the day
is I'm curious what is the risk the risk
that you have that you've been sitting
on that you haven't taken action on but
you want to and after watching this
video and leaving the comment you're
going to leave it down in the comments
below really curious to see what you
have to say thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of an espresso and enjoy the bonus
[Music]
I think people have terrible risk
calculus in general even people who try
to be really good about this are bad at
it the answer I think is almost always a
you're wrong about what is risking what
it's not risky and B most people don't
take enough risk especially early in
your career being on young and unknown
and poor that is actually a great gift
in terms of the amount of risk you can
take and I think people don't capitalize
on that enough I think what risk
actually looks like is not doing
something that you will then spend the
rest of your life we're grading and
there's a quote you know people regret
way more the things they didn't do them
things that they did do so if you really
believe in something there's an idea
that you're super passionate about you
know and you take a calculated risk to
start a company realizing you may forego
a couple of years of study and come in
on our job and whatever else and you
know maybe people call you a failure or
whatever that's a great risk to take and
if you don't take that risk I think you
have a very high chance that you end up
regretting that I think the wrong kind
of risk to take is where people don't
actually do things or don't commit to
something because they don't want to
fail and they over rate the risk of
failure and their reputation damage or
embarrassment or whatever I think one
really important thing to strive for in
your career is to be a doer not a talker
and the reason that people don't do
stuff one is it's hard and two is it's
risky and so you have these people that
you know want to dabble on a bunch of
different projects but never be all-in
on one and I think it's this combination
of work and risk and it's you know I
think that's really bad I think history
belongs to the doers and I think you
should take a risk actually do something
don't just sit around and talk and
organize and bring together groups and
go to thought leadership conferences and
whatever it is these people spend their
time on other than actually building
something and just take the risk of
committing to what you you have
conviction on new business formations
are way down wait
way down and venture capital is way down
well that means people are afraid of
something these are brand new business
startups a very important economic
measure way down well I think you know
to me I'm an entrepreneur and I think
that true entrepreneurs it doesn't
really matter what's going on in the
economy if they come up with a great
business idea great product they're risk
takers they're gonna go for it it
doesn't matter if the taxes are up five
percent it doesn't matter what is going
on with that they are people that just
are pioneers are gonna forge ahead and
start that business no matter what
what's the biggest risk you've taken
that you feel is made of the biggest
risk I've taken that is beautiful I want
to say cookie I mean I was very nervous
when I received this grant she wasn't
the most likable character and I've
played some pretty edgy characters but
this one was particularly a challenge
because it was primetime Network
television and I wasn't sure how people
would receive her I mean she beat her
son with a broom even though he deserved
it um she called once on a [ __ ] I mean
it was it was scary but I'm the type of
artist that if the role doesn't scare me
I don't want it because it's not gonna
change me as a person so I took a risk
and that's what you do as artists you
jump in feet first and you see where it
goes and I knew that we had something
special
I don't just jump feet first for any
project I knew this was something
special I knew that what Fox was trying
to do with Lee Daniels and tani strong
we're trying to do and what I was trying
to do was shake up television it's too
safe you know life is not safe and I
think we did that with this show so I'm
so proud to be a part of this project
and I'm so proud that Fox believed in us
and took a chance because that's what
art is about isn't it taking chances
taking risks
raise your standard Apple at the core
its core value is that we believe that
people with passion can change not one
drop of myself work depends on your
acceptance of me I don't ever give up
I'd have to be dead or completely
incapacitated hey believe nation if you
want to see my all-time favorite top ten
Rose a success I have a very special
secret video for you these are the
individual Clips that I have personally
learned the most from and applied to my
life and my business check the link the
description for details